[Música]
llevando a la vida de septiembre es un
honor para mí
estaba aquí en esta gran institución
el lugar no vivía hace menos de dos años
salí de este auditorio con un sueño un
sueño que se convirtió la mente y hoy
les quiero platicar como esa idea se
convirtió en una realidad y cómo tenemos
el poder de crear las las ideas y no
nuestros sueños en realidades
no importa si es arquitecto doctor
diseñador todos tenemos el poder de
crear
nosotros identificamos tres problemas
primero que nada la falta de visibilidad
a las causas
vamos a ver también cómo consumimos
productos sin valor impacto
y si colección en de las mangas las
causas
es por eso que nosotros somos un
movimiento social dedicado que creo que
nada a crear conciencia como a través
del amor generando innovadores
responsable para las marcas aliadas y
más que nada el cultivo de cultura donde
ayudar es fácil es cool y es contagioso
nosotros nos damos cuenta que según las
estadísticas el 55 por ciento de las
personas
es como una de estas dos pulseras y
oaxaca
pones cofres riestra y es por eso que
todas las empresas tienen la necesidad
de responsabilidad social y hay más de
doscientas naciones del mundo
nosotros tenemos el poder de ser el
enlace entre una y otra como conectando
de manera creativa e innovadora como lo
hacemos primero que nada
creamos sus ediciones especiales para
diferentes causas adaptados servicios
y productos para dar visibilidad y apoyo
fomentamos la unión a través de eventos
un 50/50 que busca inspirar las tres
creaciones a crear conciertos suyos que
sean mentales pero el género ayuda es
por eso que esta responsabilidad unirnos
y buscar una sociedad más sana más se
cree más limpia todos somos seres todos
queremos el potencial y es por eso que
cada vez más personas más marcas y más
celebridades se están comiendo menos
nosotros tenemos el poder de ser la
atención a este mundo y nosotros somos
ellos como les platicaba sangre este
auditorio para emprender un viaje ella
que decida una mentalidad pero regresaba
de un viaje de cualquier joven podría
venir seis meses con tus amigos
sin tiempo sin clientes pero tuve un
problema estando en ese auge
necesito pensar yo porque no estoy
haciendo nada
regresé a méxico regresé a méxico porque
mi hijo davi él
toda bolita falleció y jóvenes entre
noviembre y diciembre y tenía en trabajo
en universidad en la voz como tenía ocho
meses para hacer lo que quería y mi papá
a entrar a los despachos de abogados
donde no sólo estaba trabajando estaba
siempre el número uno era entre mejor
sacaba copias el chofer era torres y
dije yo bendice
yo cuando hablé con mis hermanos y su
apoyo
allí es donde se han acelerado las
convocatorias busca dar puedes presentar
tu ideal y puede ser que tengas éxito
entonces planteamos un mundo de las
ideas
y fuimos un acelerador obras generadoras
donde presenté en diciembre y llega
alrededor de 70 proyectos y de esos 70
sólo a ciertamente me acuerdo que yo
llegué con mis hermanos con los que
ellos estaban con nosotros
cuando hubiera sido la marca de lo que
había pasado con esa marca ha
posicionado a la número uno hay
publicidad que pasa 10 nosotros somos
diferentes retos con marcas para que
apoyen a diferentes causas mina no te
entendemos pero felicidades
en ese momento yo vine a mi sueño ya
hecho la realidad sólo vio dos problemas
como patrón saber dónde está el
programador o el diseñador no había nada
de eso
entonces está bien había cometido y el
otro problema más fuerte es de comunión
que no va la roma no está como que se
adapta al tráfico de repente termina la
roma de 96 dejarlos
pero yo aquí
en su poder
tu sueño hecho realidad
eres momento
[Música]
cuando él
sin agua
y
debes cómico
d
pero comenzamos a dar este paso
ese era mi amigo no estaba haciendo eso
la verdad
de momento la aceleradora
muy bien eso pero te quiero felicitar
por
barkos
personas
como puede ser que 400
i
después otra vez las hojas entonces cada
vez está pasando una estrategia cada
quesadilla una persona
es como un poco largos empiezas el sueño
y se empieza a comer
pero que empieza a pasar cuatro personas
cada vez las personas
y la gente
y amigos y se acabó las importantes
salidas pero esto es un todo
[Aplausos]
en persona
lo que necesito y el bolso
justo es mi fobia
vista
hágalo con fernando
nada
la fundación de beso encuentro de
botellas
ahora sueño
y el chavo no sólo contigo sin botellas
porque siendo sus buenas botellas con
los ojos cerrados
pero han sido eso
y luego que pasa el viento el primero me
encuentro con la oportunidad de empezar
a contactar a la fundación santiago
y
y por qué
y eso mismo a través de trabajo y
esfuerzo para llegar a una meta
yo vendía de nada sólo mi fe de las
deseadas de buscar las oportunidades
no necesitas
en sabiduría
es algo que todos usaron que todos
tenemos
alfonso todas formas me encanta de todas
maneras y de tu ciudades
y
a la unión
juntos
en el momento de la pista de los 50 son
versiones
desde el 20 de mayo y el segundo me
despertaba cada día organización más por
favor no te voy a soñar
en 20 minutos
en 20 días 17 fundaciones y
discriminaciones
lo asumimos
de viejos momento único ausente 14 de
junio donde lanzamos el proyecto
en ese momento de nuestro
el esfuerzo de almas cuando llegan a su
límite en el proyecto si es cambio
porque cuando las cosas pasan
pero si ustedes quieren
la tierra
es el único valor
hoy lo que me gusta
todos tenemos ese momento de generar un
cambio de la sociedad de chicos podemos
que se lo contamos
tenemos que estar en la mejor época
no decidimos de londres mimos pero
seamos coherentes la luz está en
nuestras manos porque juntos estamos muy
cerca de estar muy lejos muchas gracias
[Aplausos]